hey everybody it's Mike from motor flows
and in this video I'm going to talk
about the order flow Delta now order
flow Delta differs from options Delta
right options Delta is the theoretical
estimate of how much an options value
may change given a one dollar move up or
down in the underlying uh security Now
with order flow when we talk about Delta
it's the net difference of aggressive
buyers versus aggressive sellers in a
bar remember right the market moves in a
two-way auction there's a bid there's an
offer
and when someone crosses the bid an
offer either to buy the offer or sell
the bid they are the aggressor and that
would either register as plus one if it
was aggressive buyer as positive Delta
or -1 as negative Delta if it was an
aggressive seller now there's different
ways that you could actually look at
Delta
and on most order flow charts it will
appear along the bottom
it could have Delta there's actually Max
Delta Min Delta cumulative Delta and
there's a few other little other ways of
doing it they do like percentages of
bars cumulative Delta divided by volume
but for the most part most Traders look
at uh the Delta the headline number the
max Delta the mid Delta and cumulative
Delta now every bar is going to have a
Delta and once the bar closes the Delta
is not going to change but as the bar is
forming obviously Delta will still
change because they're still trading
taking place in the bar now the reason
I'm making this video is because I was
triggered I got triggered I was on
social media the other day and you know
just reading things about order flow and
somebody that's got you know kind of a
decent following says Delta doesn't
matter right I mean there's no value in
looking at the delta in order flow it
has no impact on price movements and I I
gotta admit I was triggered because I do
use Delta in my analysis now you know
for someone to say that
you know maybe you know he does hasn't
met anybody that's using Delta in their
trading or you know hasn't understood
how to implement it with his own trading
right I know this guy is big on
imbalances and honestly imbalances is a
form of aggressive trading right you
have obviously you've got aggressive
buyers or aggressive sellers causing an
imbalance and Delta is just another way
to look at it now
there's like I said there's different
forms of Delta right there's the
headline number and that's what most
Traders look at right so you can see
Delta
appearing you know like this bar right
here in the middle minus 196 this bar
here positive 236 this one minus 52
minus 58 uh 140 381 and this is the
number right when when I say Delta like
the headline number the Delta is what
most Traders key in on they don't really
take it even a step further and look at
Max Delta and Min Delta Max Delta is the
most positive Delta was in a bar Min
Delta is the most weak it was in the bar
or the strongest selling it was in a bar
so for example Max Delta is say you know
256 that means at one point the
strongest that the positive Delta was
was Plus 256.
if mendelta was you know minus 130 then
the strongest it was in terms of
aggressive selling in that bar was minus
130.
now you could have Delta could be zero
okay to me that just more of coincidence
happening when the final Delta lands at
zero is just probably because the bar
closed for whatever reason right
especially if you're looking at a
time-based chart you know it's goes by
time if you look at a volume it goes by
volume and it just so happened that you
know the way Trading
panned out in that bar it just ended at
zero you know if there's another
nanosecond it maybe could have been plus
10 or minus five or who knows you know
or
um
don't read too much into it don't think
oh it landed on zero that must mean
something however when you look at Max
Delta and Min Delta you do see them
landing on zero and that does tell you
something right so if you see obviously
like this red candle here you've got Max
Delta of zero Min Delta of minus 87 at
no point was their net aggressive buying
in that bar now there is going to be
aggressive buying right they are going
to trade on the offer there's going to
be aggressive buyers but it what it's
telling you is this bar was under
pressure from the get-go right meaning
there's always been more selling
pressure than buying pressure in this
bar
and there's going to be times where you
have Min Delta being zero right you see
here this green bar right it's got Min
Delta of zero Max Delta of 18 final
Delta of 13. so
what happened was there was yes there
was selling into the bid but there was
always more aggressive buying taking
place in that bar now
one of the ways I like to use Max and
Min Delta is look at it in relation to
um where the final Delta is okay so if I
see
uh Min Delta like this one minus 87 Max
Delta zero okay it's not I I it's got a
I got a good idea that there's strong
aggressive selling taking place
minus 68 it's close to minus 87 so I
know that it's closing right near its
Min Delta number right so I know that
the the selling is strong now people say
what about this one right the max Delta
is 18 Min Delta zero we closed at 13
so we're only five contracts off of our
Max Delta well yes I understand that
argument and normally I make that
argument which I'm going to show you in
a second but when I look at the headline
Delta numbers I have a number depending
on the market I have numbers in my head
of what I consider to be a normal order
flow Delta right if I start seeing small
Deltas like this 13 it's under this
threshold that I have of about 50
contracts meaning you know if Delta
could be plus or minus 50
to have meaning so if it's coming in at
13 you know it could very have easily
gone negative Delta if there was you
know five more seconds in
you know or one more trade went through
before
um the bar closed so
I don't put too much into it but when I
get down here right so I could see right
there's strong selling in this bar minus
87 0 Max Delta right Market sells off a
bit here now it starts to turn and as
it's turning
I see these two bars right here right
you can see Delta is 140 Delta is 381
Min Delta on these two bars is zero
first bar here Max Deltas 189 we close
that positive 140. that's encouraging
here you got Max Delta of 388 we closed
at 381 so we're closing right near our
Max Delta number
then obviously in this next bar here we
got Min Delta minus 13. again you know
this bar came down poke through the the
swing low here and then came back up but
Max Delta is 107 we closed at 107 so I'm
starting to see some signs of strong
aggressive buying taking place now there
is aggressive selling In These Bars
obviously people are selling into this
onto the bid here
but at no point was it really dominant
in control of this bar right you see as
the market starts moving back up now you
know another way Traders like to look at
Delta I mean I I actually have a course
on Delta but um you know I don't want to
be pimping the course out here rather I
just want to be talking about you know
different ways you could use Delta and
you know a simple way is there are what
they call what I call Delta candles
um
yeah if you're on a ninja Trader on the
paid version I forgot what it's called
it's called like order flow cumulative
Delta or something like that and you
could look at Delta per bar as a candle
or in cumulative Delta right as the
market is moving up how the Delta is
transacting some people I know actually
like to look at Delta as opposed to
price and take training decisions based
off what's happening in the Delta not
what's happening in price but this
morning right today was
um Labor Day in the US so markets are
quiet very quiet
and you can see here right this was uh
you know just before seven in the
morning Market is sort of grinding us a
little way up up then you got big
aggressive buying here right
big bar up you know you look at the
Delta you're like wow that's so big but
you know again it's relative to what the
Delta is coming in here
so it's Plus 115.
you come up here start making the swing
High here okay and what's happening in
Delta nothing's happening in Delta you
got minus one minus seven minus 22 minus
26 actually Delta is starting to turn
negative now again these are very small
numbers this is actually what we call a
Delta surge we're sort of growing
directionally in strength
minus 1 minus seven minus 22.
and what happens the market market
starts selling off right and you know
this is sort of a pattern that you would
see
during the day quite often right so you
know that's another way you can use
Delta right you could use the Delta
candles like this and it's gotten to the
point where now we're Traders aren't
even looking at a footprint chart or
they're looking at a Delta chart right
this is the Delta candles on the bottom
here we've got
um
this is the bar by bar Delta as opposed
to having to look at you know say the
numbers here right sometimes it's easier
just look at how it's formed on a
Candlestick right and the mind processes
images much faster than words and
numbers so if you could look at a candle
and say oh yeah that's bullish or
bearish you know that's gonna
give you a faster reaction time down
here is cumulative Delta and you know
today is
let's say presence they today's Labor
Day and again it was quiet but you know
Friday was was a bit active in terms of
you know Market activity because it was
non-farm payrolls and if you remember
right Market uh started rallying you
know we opened obviously the market
rallied off the number made a new high
came off made a new High
um you know in the morning and then it
had this big dramatic sell-off now to
say that Delta is useless to you
look at this high up here okay
see if I could draw a line here
excuse me so you got a high up here
right we came up here once twice third
time
and if you're just watching it trying to
you have a high of the day okay and
anytime you're at the high of the day
you got to be asking are we going to go
higher or not are we going to take it
out or are we just going to sputter
around and and sell off and what's
happened if you're looking at the Delta
you can see it's really sputtering
around any Deltas that come in here are
big negative Deltas big negative Deltas
this is from the time the high is made
and what happens eventually the market
has this big dramatic sell-off but you
can just see in here right we're coming
back up towards this high right we had
some selling here some aggressive buying
right positive Deltas we're going back
up to the high maybe this is it maybe
we're gonna you know should I be fomo
Wing in or not but what you're seeing is
these small Deltas up in here
right again which is a sign of
absorption meaning you know because
people are trading but it's they're
evenly matched
right there there's buyers that are
Sellers and they can't really push the
market anymore they can't get it any
higher because why people are coming in
with Supply
and they're able to distribute that
Supply up here without really moving the
market now the best place to sell
if you have a lot of supply
is as the Market's been rallying right
you don't want to be selling you're
dumping your supply when the Market's
dropping because if you do that's this
is what happens you get those big bars
like this obviously it shows up in the
Delta with all the selling but if the
market is rallying and you got Supply
distribute it right that's what we do on
the institutional desks right I've
worked at JP Morgan I've worked at
Cargill I've worked at Commerce Bank
in a rising market that's the easiest
place to to get rid of Supply right
because you have plenty of buyers when
the market starts dropping you're gonna
add to that drop you're going to
add fuel to that fire and then you're
gonna get those big bars down right and
these big bars down everyone that's
sitting you know in front of a screen
sees that oh my gosh it's big selling so
if you got a lot to distribute you're
going to distribute it up here near the
highs where everyone is looking to buy
and you're going to often end up with
smaller Deltas Deltas Contracting
Okay so
that's how
you can use Delta I mean there's many
different ways there's actually
Delta Footprints which you know if you
want to look at Delta at Price you can
there's diagonal Delta Footprints as
well
um you know the next video or two I'll
talk about
Delta Footprints because you know any
Edge that you can find in the market
that makes sense to you that can improve
your Trading is going to make you a
better Trader and ultimately it's going
to make you more successful Trader so
don't dismiss something just because
somebody posts something on social media
that I don't know anybody that's using
Delta successfully well okay maybe they
just don't know anybody that uses it
fine okay I mean I don't know anybody
that uses
well actually I do know people that use
moon phases but you know
there's there's so many different ways
to analyze the market just because you
don't know somebody that's doing it
doesn't mean it can't be done so anyway
guys I hope you like this video be sure
to like And subscribe the channel and
look out for my next video again I'll
probably follow it up on Delta
Footprints so enjoy bye bye